we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's a really fair question about
covet hospitalizations and something i
said earlier this week let's take a
listen to it i welcome these types of uh
confrontations with the things that i
say because they're fair let's listen
hey david i had a question you were just
talking about um how hospit the
hospitalization data you were saying
that even though the hospitalizations
look high they're saying that not all of
the hospitalizations are because of
covid like a broken leg and they just
happen to also have code or something
and that makes sense but i remember in
the beginning of the pandemic
um there were you know a bunch of right
wingers making the same argument they're
like oh the hospitalizations are
overrated you know they're they're
pretending like it's covered when the
person really died of this and we were
kind of discounting that as just kind of
you know their their same old
shenanigans of just deflecting you know
finding any excuse to like downplay the
severity so why is it now something that
we're saying
like is there something specific about
the data that is showing us so now
that's really the case yes that's
exactly it this is a great question
which is for a long time republicans
have been saying they haven't so much
been saying the hospitalization numbers
are exaggerated republicans have been
saying the death numbers are being
exaggerated and at one point they were
saying hospitals lie and say someone
died from kovid to get more money now we
debunked that what is true is that if
someone is in the hospital for kovid on
average it's more expensive to treat
them than when someone does not have
covid so it doesn't matter if they die
or not medicare reimburses more money if
someone actually is treated for covid
because on average that's more expensive
to treat the difference is before there
was no data that pointed to a ton of the
people in the hospital with covid
being in the hospital for something else
before
you had a situation where
almost anything that was elective or
non-emergency was shut down
the hospitalization rate for the earlier
strains was higher
and there was no data that suggested
many of the people hospitalized right
now with covet are actually here for
something else we now have actual data
including for example from new york city
omicron is so contagious it is so
widespread and it is also asymptomatic
in so many people that in new york city
half of those in the hospital with
kovid
were not in the hospital because of
covid they are not being treated with
covet they incidentally are positive but
they're there for something else so the
reason why we now can say that and
before we couldn't is that the data
actually reflects that it's a perfectly
fair question
and that's the answer uh and they're
exactly the types of questions that we
should be asking we have a great bonus
show for you today
we'll talk about novak djokovic facing
prison for breaking isolation while
coveted positive this guy is just
disgusting we'll talk about bernie
sanders uh plan for everybody to get n95
masks not crappy masks and we will talk
about info wars and alex jones claims
about being barely able to pay the bills
after they brought in 165 million
dollars in three years
get access to today's bonus show by
signing up at
joinpackman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22 wow 22 to get a discount
we'll see you on the bonus show
one of our sponsors is real paper our
forests on earth remove about a quarter
of the carbon that humans put into the
atmosphere and yet every day we're
cutting down tens of thousands of trees
to make single-use paper products real
paper is fighting back real paper makes
paper products that are truly
sustainable their paper towels and
toilet paper are 100 percent plastic
free made without any virgin tree fibers
meaning no new trees are cut down but
real paper is super soft and durable you
don't have to sacrifice quality to help
the planet these are great products from
a usability standpoint i'm using real
paper at home you can do a one-time
purchase they also have easy
subscriptions all orders ship in 100
recyclable plastic free packaging
everybody needs paper towels and toilet
paper buy ones that you will feel good
about and they're giving my audience
thirty percent off a subscription when
you go to
realpaper.compacman and use the code
pacman the link is down below